top chefs from all over Europe rave
about this butter and gladly serve it in
their gourmet restaurants and this is
where it comes from about half an hour's
drive north of gothenburg in sweden
xanterra bring and Patrick Johan Sean
spent around a year experimenting with
different butter recipes and production
methods they first asked a top chef to
try their butter four years ago he loved
it and immediately ordered 40 kilograms
to know it's separated into butter and
buttermilk my grandmother she was a
butter maker in the 40s 50s and 60s and
she taught me to wash away all traces of
this buttermilk this white hair because
then the butter will keep longer but we
do not do as my grandmother taught me we
keep the buttermilk inside that well we
have lots more flavor homemade sour
cream is the second reason for the
butter special taste the couple leave
the sour cream to ferment for three days
with special bacterial cultures it's
then whipped in a machine which
separates the butter and the buttermilk
about 200 kilograms are produced each
week and sent to 20 or so top
restaurants across Europe kilo costs
around 18 euros
the industrial butter is made in a
modern machine it takes the whole
process takes a couple of seconds we
give it love we pay attention to it and
from the beginning the cream it's the
most tastiest we buy it from a local
dairy and we know the the farmers around
the area and the cream is really good
their customers include the
award-winning Norma restaurant in
Copenhagen head chef Stefan Kyle Sean
orders around four kilos of the butter
every week for the Michelin star for
restaurant in Gothenburg car Sean serves
the butter with bread he says it's much
too good for cooking that he broken all
here blonde Tavia hmmm this handmade
butter it's it had the right sourness it
has a right saltness and you can find a
little bit of the buttermilk still in
the butter and it gives a lot of flavor
for the butter so it's for me it's the
most perfect butter to use tweeting on
bread
bring and your hunch on still enjoy
experimenting they have buried their
butter in the Swedish woods in soil that
is almost devoid of oxygen that prevents
the butter from spoiling the batter will
be left to mature over a seven-year
period the idea stems from centuries old
butter found in the Moors in Ireland and
Scotland back then that's how father was
made to last although it might have been
very for religious reasons it gets more
mature but it doesn't get rancid there
is no off taste and it's to me it's
really beautiful the taste some
variations because we buried it with
cloth like this or with bartsch from
birch trees and pine trees and of course
the pine tree gave the butter some
tastes
great food starts with top ingredients
and one of those is most definitely the
butter made by Sandra bring and Patrick
Johan shop
you